اثار دماء تلطخ الطريقه المتاخمه لهذا
الحي السكني بمدينه خرسون مدينه لم يعرف
لها السلم ولا الامن طريقه فالمدفعيات
الروسيه قصفت من جديدنا المدينه الواقعه
في جنوب اوكرانيا لتستهدف مناطق سكنيه
وتخلف حاله من الذعر والهلع لدى السكان
قبل ساعتين قصفت المدفعيات هذه الشقه احد
الصاروخان سقطه هنا والاخر هناك الفتاه
التي كانت تعيش في هذه الشقه لاقت مصرعها
للاسف
الاداره الاقليميه
سكنيه ما اسفر عن مقتل عدد من المدنيين
واصابه اخرين ورغم خروج القوات الروسيه من
هذه المدينه في نوفمبر الماضي الا انها لا
تزال في مرمى النيران الروسيه
القذائف كانت تسقط في حديقتنا اصبت انا
ايضا كانت تدين نافذه كبيره واصبت في وجهي
بشضيتين من زجاجها عندما كنت اقوم بتخزين
المياه كان ذلك قبل شهرين الجرح اختفى
الان
وضمن مساعيها الى تحقيق التقدم في منطقه
الجمباز اكدت مجموعه فغنر العسكريه
الروسيه انها استولت على بلده ابله داتني
الواقعه في منطقه دنيتك وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه لم تؤكد روايه غمر فيما اعلن
الجيش الاخراني عن صد هجوم قرب القريه